[Music]
let's go to anne in san antonio what's
up ann
hi how are you i'm good and you
i'm pretty good pretty good hot in texas
is it still a thousand degrees
yes has it rained yet
um we got the
oh god the tear it like a small
sprinkle of a rain it was such tease
the clouds rolled in
everything looked good there was
lightning and then it rained for two
minutes and stopped it was awful there's
just like a bunch of people spitting in
the front yard and that's about it i'm
sorry that's what it felt like and hey
here's what's here's everyone that i
know in texas is waiting for
it will all catch up in a weekend and
then flood everything right so it'll be
like oh we need 10 inches of rain here
which is the annual average let's do it
on a wednesday at four right and then
anyway i'm sorry
so how can i help i wish i was a
meteorologist i just can't do anything
about it
i know it's all right what's up um
my husband
um last week he went to our his local
gym
and there was an active shooter
situation
and he saw everything he saw the person
be murdered
oh it's an active shooter it wasn't
somebody just pulled a gun
to get shot okay
yes someone got shot okay yes
and he witnessed everything
thankfully his job is in on threat
assessment he didn't follow the crowd
um he actually got the group around him
out of the emergency exits you know
because he takes a mental map of
everywhere he goes right and then went
back into the building once the shooter
he didn't see the shooter anymore and
went to help whoever got shot
but unfortunately the person who got
shot was dead yeah
i'm so sorry man
what a heroic husband you have right
no he's amazing yeah
were you at the gym
no but i'm just going on my intuition
for whatever reason that day yeah um
uh here's what here's what i'm asking
i'm asking you're wearing this heavily
yeah
how is it
how are you wearing it
are you are you that i almost lost my
husband or i could have lost my husband
he was right there he's that close or
i'm heartbroken and worried that he saw
this and went through this like where's
your heart on this
i think all of it
especially that's the gym i told him not
to go to
i told you shows aren't the super best
way to approach this but
it's not and i definitely did not and
when he called me he's like hey don't
freak out i'm like okay sure
listen let me just take a side here
good people of the podcast land
especially you gentlemen
don't ever call someone you love
especially your wife and say
start the call with hey don't freak out
don't do that
um because that's a recipe for a total
freak out okay that was just my public
service announcement back to you anne
okay
so your husband saw some hard stuff
what's it been like since then
um he tends to hold things in so that's
why i'm concerned
um he came back he came back home and he
tried to play it off you know try to
have some dark humor in it
but i you know we are both in the marine
corps together
and that's where we met so i already you
know seen it we have a lot of friends
who are unfortunately committed to my
side
and that's where my mind is going
okay
that you're worried that because he
experienced this ultimately it's going
to lead to him taking his
uh taking his life dying by suicide
um i think i don't know if it would ever
go there but you know when i did bring
up you know you know maybe you should
get some counseling maybe there's
someone you can talk to
um he said no outright and
no i think that's stupid and useless and
i think it's because of our friends who
have gone through
the type of system and it didn't help
yeah
okay
so here's what i want you to do in this
situation here's a couple of things okay
number one
um i know you're a veteran i know you're
a marine or you've seen a lot of stuff
i want you to take ownership of your
trauma involved here secondary traumatic
stress is a real thing
okay
and trauma's cumulative it adds up over
time
and so it might be un it might feel
weird that this is affecting you so much
and you aren't even there
but here's the thing
it just piles onto your body on top of
the other traumas you've experienced
firsthand or vicariously
okay so trauma's cumulative you've heard
me talk about the backpack
you've you're if your backpack's already
filled to the brim and someone just
rests a brick on it at some point it all
falls over okay that's where you are
right now
so don't think you're crazy because you
can't stop thinking about this and you
aren't even there
okay
but i want you to take ownership that
this is your trauma
because it's easy for you to feel
unmoored and untethered and not well and
then to dump all of that on him and his
lack of response and he's not responding
in a way that you think he should be
responding after going through a really
harrowing situation
okay
i will tell you personally
and i'm going to go ahead and just give
a warning here to anybody listening if
there's little ears in the room you
probably want to have them head out okay
so ann
i've been in situations where i've seen
the insides of people's bodies on the
outside you too have you two
yes unfortunately okay
and it's very very different than the
movies right
yeah
and when you're watching a movie you
don't smell
and you don't have to watch your hands
and where you're stepping where you're
leaning right so i'm getting real
graphic here but here's what i'm trying
to tell you i've been there and as a as
almost as a meta
i've been really surprised at how it
didn't affect me like i thought it would
to the point that i went and saw a
counselor because i thought i was a
psychopath
where it did affect me though
so i didn't shut me down i gallow's
humor is how i handle that stuff and so
um it was some real dark dark humor
making jokes that were inappropriate um
and my circle of friends got pretty
tight because there's a few only a few
people i could talk to about it
where it came out was i got real short
with people that i loved or i wasn't
sleeping very good which over time made
me
uh or encouraged me
open up an avenue where i made some poor
diet choices which then right so it
affected me in weird ways but not in the
ways i would have thought okay
here's why that's important for you
don't put your
picture of how he should be handling
this on to him that's gonna cause a
division in your relationship
what i'd much rather you do is sit down
with him and say
i'm gonna go talk to somebody because
this is affecting me
i'm taking ownership of my
mental health and wellness i'm a call
local counselor
i need you to promise me that if you're
not okay you will reach out
okay
and
here's another important one and my wife
has been a gift here
she has not
like we don't talk like when i was doing
christ like i wouldn't talk about what i
saw i wouldn't bring that stuff up that
wasn't fair to come back from a scene
and then just dump that on her
but she sure did call out hey you really
have an energy about you that you're
looking for a fight
and it's making me uncomfortable i'd be
like i'm not looking for a fight and she
goes i know but i just need you to you
are radioactive or i can tell the last
five nights you haven't slept all night
you're tossing and turning
and so she called out my behavior she
didn't try to armchair diagnose me she
didn't tell me i was doing something
wrong she didn't tell me i was screwing
something up she did call out my
behavior as someone who loves me and who
spends a lot of time with me do you get
the difference there
yeah and i didn't do anything i just
mention it just like hey and
i did mention it to him like hey maybe
if there's someone you talk to and you
know it was out of his behavior and i
said it just like that you know not
pushing it on him or anything or patient
and i only brought it up once and let it
go okay so he was already what's his
behavior not
he's usually a happy-go-lucky guy i mean
he's very
approachable everybody really really
loves him and that's kind of why i was
concerned because i do see his behavior
changing he said it doesn't affect him
but i do catch a glint like i do pay
attention to him
to where a couple days after it happened
he was just staring off into space even
the the night it happened he was just
staring off in his face and i didn't
push it i didn't pressure him and the
first one of the first things they did
was you know after he said you don't
want to counseling i reached out to a
couple of his best friends and
let them know what happened and just
said hey you know
i don't want you to be caught off guard
if he does need to talk to somebody like
he does as of right now he doesn't want
to do you know talk to a counselor or
anything like that like and he
seemed like he would like he was okay
about it but i
knew since my older sister also has ptsd
who's that's gone untreated
we're dealing with her rage fits and
everything too and stuff but here's the
thing let's deal with the behavior not
with the pseudo diagnosis okay
yeah so if you see him staring off into
space and one of the things it's funny
you mentioned that because that's
exactly what my wife would call out she
would say you're here but you're not
here and she would just say it very
quietly hey you're with us but you're
not with us
or she would say come back to us that
was her quiet thing and she would do it
very gently and quietly and she'd put
her hand on me like she would touch my
hand or touch my leg and say
hey come back to us and we would do that
at dinner party and i would just be
staring off into space didn't even
realize i'd left the room and i had okay
it wasn't
hey you need to go to see a counselor
and because your depression is it wasn't
that because that would have walled me
off i would have said i'm not i'm fine
i'm completely fine i'm sitting here at
dinner laughing i'm having a good time
it was
hey come back to us
and
you promise you will call if if you feel
like something's going south if you feel
like you're hurting yourself
uh yes i promise that's it i'm not gonna
try to arm chair diagnose you i'm gonna
call it behavior hey you're getting
really loud and really angry i'm not
okay with that i'm gonna take the kid
and i'm gonna i'm gonna leave because
this is me you see what i'm saying we're
talking about the behavior not the
diagnosis and not the solution we're
gonna let them
find their path towards that solution
okay
and if you see something troubling
like all of a sudden guns are out more
than they usually are or
he's starting to give stuff away to some
stuff that is his prized possessions or
he starts getting throwing things away
um he starts talking about
missing some of his friends who died by
suicide if if you start getting nervous
then you call everyone you know right
you call
everybody but this sounds to me
like you are struggling with this and i
want you to take ownership of what
you're struggling with okay
are you there
i'm here yeah will you do that
i can why won't you
you're not going to i know you're not i
know you're not i know i have a lot of
friends who are tough veterans you're
not going to why won't you
and just pretend we're having a beer and
some nachos and i'm just sitting across
the table from you this isn't me like
talking down at you like i'm smiling
like why why won't you
i have other things to worry about like
what
um we just moved to the area one thing
um we have a six-year-old kid trying to
get him
adjusted to a new moving place where
you're here based kind of alone
yep
um
my husband travels for work
okay
so most of the time i'm holding it don't
mess whole
yep i have a chance to worry about
you sound tired
i'm exhausted
so let me tell you the single greatest
gift you could give your your
is this a six-year-old little boy or a
little girl
he's a boy okay
the single greatest gift you could give
your little boy and the single greatest
gift you could give your husband is
connection
not that they're getting a performance
not that they're getting a
shell of you
but that they're fully getting you
and so what that means is the greatest
gift you could give your son and the
greatest gift you could give your
husband is to get well
because the the evil of trauma is that
it disconnects us from relationship
because other people die other people
hurt us
and so other people become the thing our
body tries to protect us from and
unfortunately it's the only thing that
keeps us well as other people
see you see how it's a mess
yep
and you're exhausted and now you're real
lonely too right
yeah
yeah i feel like i take care of everyone
around me and i kind of just you do i
don't i don't i don't go to the doctor
unless um my leg's falling off or
something
and
that's not brave
it's good it's dumb
it's just dumb
it's efficient for everyone else but
myself it's not though
you're giving them 65
they deserve more of you
and they can only get more of you if you
will get well
yeah i i agree
have you seen hard hard stuff
like what
in terms of death and
some of that carnage that comes along
with that
um i have
but i also
i did take your aces score i'm a nine
that's what i was getting this is test
score yes often those of us who find
ourselves in helping roles are helping
because we have to
right
yeah
yeah
i would love love love
for you to be at your six-year-old's
wedding
and i would love love love
for you to be that crazy
crazy san antonio grandma
for his little knuckleheaded kids he's
gonna have
well that's what i tell my husband all
the time i'm like when i'm old i just
want to sit on a front porch with a
hound dog and throw pine cones at people
walking by oh gosh we're the same person
dude i've had basset hounds my whole
life and as soon as my last as soon as
josephine goes to college i'm getting
more hound dogs they're disgusting and
gross and loud and i love them
yes but here's the thing
that picture you have to reverse
engineer just like a mission here's our
objective and so what do we have to do
starting today to make that happen
and so you're playing a long game and
right now you are caught in a common
trauma response which is i just need to
get to the next hour and then the next
hour and then the next hour and then i
collapse at night
usually i take something to go to sleep
and then i prop myself up with chemicals
when i wake up and i start the whole
thing over again
and i want you to start playing a longer
game here
okay and that starts with you calling a
counselor in san antonio and saying i'm
new to the area
my aces score is a nine
and i'm ready to go to work on me
and you're probably gonna have to take a
yoga class you probably have to get
massage you're gonna have to learn what
good touch and healthy touch is and
you're gonna have to learn
how to write in journal you have to
learn all this new crap
it's gonna be like come on man
yeah i mean i do
um mixed martial arts and maybe my
husband just started dance lessons
because i didn't want to miss i didn't
want
a disconnection
a lot of us outside our comfort zone
keeps us close connected so we have no
choice too genius genius i love it
love love love it
and the last true
intimate connection is two former
marines
getting past the wall
and
being
emotionally vulnerable and intimate when
it comes to what i'm thinking and what
my needs are
and what i love and what i want to do
one day yeah and it's basically been
us
the entire time we've moved every moved
everywhere together we got married when
we're 18. yep it was just they've just
it's just been us yeah and
we
yeah it's just it's been us looking out
for each other
i know but you're looking out for each
other in a performative way
you're not with each other you're trying
to protect each other
so you see the difference right yes yeah
we're protecting each other that's
exactly
and you get in this weird circle he
wakes up and feels that you're a hundred
miles away from him even though you're
three inches away from him in bed and he
sets off to protect you and help how is
he going to do that he has no one to
shoot anymore and so he's going to go
earn a bunch of money
and he's going to he's going to do what
he's got to do because he's just going
to follow the script on how to take care
of a wife in texas and you're gonna wake
up and realize husband just took off
again to another town to another job to
another thing
and i need to protect him because he's
gonna be busy he's gonna be doing these
things and so i'm gonna get a bunch of
tasks
and he's gonna get a bunch of tasks and
a bunch of jobs
and none of that will address
are you with me
yes
and i think a lot of it too is that we
both come from a similar background so
we're kind of dedicated ourselves to
changing
our
the changing cycles awesome that's i
mean that's amazing it's amazing
that's incredible
if i sent you two copies of
own your past change your future would
you all read them together
i already have it you got it have you
read it yeah
um it's in my audible i'm actually on
chapter three okay
um
stay on the line i'm gonna send you two
hard copies you can audible it too but
if y'all will go through that together
it will give you something to point at
yeah and there's a few chapters in there
he can roll his eyes at and be like oh
this is so dumb
yeah that's exactly what he's gonna do
of course he is and you can just laugh
and you can tell them to call me don't
call me we could roll our eyes together
it's fine
um okay but
it will give you an entry point too what
do you think about that
and what do you think about that
and i think this is stupid why do you
think that's stupid
and it gives you an entry point into a
conversation okay
i'm sorry that he experienced this i'm
so glad he was there
to save a bunch of people's lives and
i'm glad he's got you to come home and
anchor into
yeah we balance each other really well
you do
yeah we balance each other really well
where he's weak i'm strong or i'm strong
he's weak and
i want to introduce you to a life not on
the teeter-totter
yeah
where it doesn't have to balance
right where it's like
saying that out loud just now
that's such a military of course it is
the way you solve problems
oh my god hey hold on there's some
greatness to that you have a framework
that most people walking on the street
don't have
and here's the thing you've heard me say
this a million times on the show
the framework that keeps you alive
can be the framework in a different
time and period at a time
the things that you do to keep you alive
when you're a kid are the things that
are going to blow your marriage up the
things that you do in the military the
way you solve problems the way you have
to have step-by-step instructions so
that we can get this mission
that is amazing
and if the strategies in the plan become
more important than your wife or your
husband when you're newlyweds trying to
figure out life outside of the military
it can become constrictive right so
don't throw that stuff out you may laugh
and catch it be like oh sound like i'm
in the military again that's fine
he's lucky to have you
and my hope for you guys is this y'all
are doing they are amazing amazing
my hope is
that y'all can say hey
we are doing all of these things
he is all in on loving you and you are
all in on loving him and you're both all
in on taking care of that kid and you
it's common you're taking the line share
the work and you're exhausted and you're
running and you're running and you're
lonely in a new town all those things
my dream for you is that you
would say hey i'm gonna stop driving at
95 miles an hour i'm gonna back it down
to 60 55 and put on cruise control for a
while
i'm gonna go sit down and say some
things out loud for the first time in my
life about what life was when i was a
kid the things i've been through the
things i've seen things i've experienced
in the military and it's gonna be
uncomfortable and it's gonna be gnarly
and i'm gonna learn some new skills and
i'm gonna process some old traumas so
that
i will be the most present wife the most
present mom i will be the most at peace
my body will be at peace so that those i
love can anchor and repel off the side
and husband by the way i want you to do
that too
that may be a harder sell but
um
we often learn by watching so and go
first you're brave i'm so grateful for
you and your husband and your service
and your gifts to our communities
and i'll walk with you every step of the
way as you all head into the new
into the new whatever right wherever it
goes